anyway speaking of live shows and
artists who are bigger than us Russ yeah
so what are you guys say about Russ
what's your Ruskin here so a lot of a
lot of people will send me as I'm sure
they do you like Russ memes and all the
time
Russ related [ __ ] it was funny because
the kids send me one the other day and I
was just like I thought I don't care
about him anymore huh I know it's but
it's a funny reverse now he's winning
with me psychologically how so well so I
I wanted to shoot actually a sketch okay
and I thought about it being you me nick
colletti and spock okay and then I
imagine like you kick off a joke about
Russ like oh I rest right uh-huh you
might be out of focus but none oh yeah
right I'm trying to sit up a little bit
yeah announcer and so I thought I
thought about like everyone laughing
that I could just play some guy in the
corner who's just like kind of look so
anything hmm
I think just the three of them look at
each other and they go I'm sorry dude do
you what what was that like what was
what we said like russ was like yeah and
I heard you like why didn't you laugh
not even why don't you laugh like it's
just more like so come on like let's
it's [ __ ] Russ and then you know I just
don't really care about it's [ __ ] okay
and then just gets crazy I just imagined
it clay tit Nicoletti the background
being like say it dude
say it
I don't it's weird now I don't want to
have to say say it
it's a Spock I don't want it you should
be holding him down ya know by the
throat I'm on the wall
it's say it again okay okay good
[Laughter]
now they're just like strong-arming him
and like moving them around all shitty
yeah it is right that's right yeah we're
bad yeah I knew yeah we're boy let's go
get it let's get a milkshake
yeah let's share a milkshake for straws
that's how it ends things like I don't
want to share a straw they all turn to
him punch in on what do you mean so
you're saying you want to do a sketch in
support now of Russ fans because now
it's like dick riding to hate Russ
yeah okay yeah it's weird mm-hmm it's a
weird like it's also kind of funny like
that like the secret Russ fan you know a
group of friends
oh yeah that's kind of also a funny
angle cuz there's always you know Russ
had rusted like as much as weed as much
as you don't know [ __ ] ton of fans so
that's why it was always like one
sleeper group right everyone else was
like [ __ ] Russ [ __ ] Russ and I got you
know it does everything himself right
mixes and masters all gives a [ __ ] dude
I'm just saying it takes Talent I'm
saying yeah I can I [ __ ] I clean this
house by myself so I get a [ __ ] award
for being a good husband no I just come
in and I do it talk about something else
guess I'm not really the same as music
but I mean it's fine fine whatever yeah
yeah he what are you are you I'm sorry
dude who who are you a fan of yeah what
is happening here dude I thought it was
[ __ ] Russ I mean I used to die just like
he's kind of like some of the songs are
kind of good you know what no I just to
that point I think that's what
frustrates people who are us I have no
problem hitting Russ like he has very
very mediocre
like musically it's just it's very seven
out of ten yeah okay you know it is not
really mediocre seven out of ten and
mediocre I guess like five out of ten
yeah yeah it's like just above average
and it's sometimes but it's also sure
that's easy to like well he doesn't make
anything that's like jarring or it was
super weird as beat selection it's just
it just P just picks like yeah this is
enjoyable have his music you could you
could be anyone on those tracks yeah I I
could've did his [ __ ] I could do that
[ __ ] was a model tune yeah no you
couldn't I don't think no man he's he's
he's the best true yeah yeah I don't
like have his voice I'm like I have
those like intonation and she and [ __ ]
it's funny because you just nailed it
that's exactly what he sounds like you
you're totally good oh my god dude book
a session with him go there a
personating him yeah it's like that's
like really like kind of dope and I want
to rap like that yeah yeah do is we got
to do on the next album just do a song
called rough song and it's just you
covering one of his songs in his voice
just sounds exactly the same
let me remake the beat to be way better
dude we remake one of his songs and then
halfway through we explained everything
we did to make the song it's like a
seven minute in the middle and then
that's pretty funny actually and then
the last half is this is the rest of the
song it'd be kind of funny to do a whole
song about how much work it took to make
the song 12-minute song
yeah just bake the Spotify behind the
scenes into the middle yeah yeah I don't
wanna so like for this part right like I
was like in a dark place and
[Music]
bang I'm trying to flex not trying to
flex take your fishing Norseman break
that's not a flex